I loved the first Pacific Rim in that
classic tale of robots and monsters Matt
hold weights in that holds power I grew
up watching the old giant monster movies
from Japan the classics like Ultraman
space Giants and of course Godzilla I
just ate it up
everybody has felt that feeling when
those wants to start through a city
it creates an instant excitement with
the technology we have we have a chance
to make it that much more spectacular no
decorator zoko incontinence Aniceto
science our King Cara Mata and Marco and
Steiner dominated it and of course the
model decorated coitus ultimately it's a
world conflict and everyone's put aside
their differences and come together many
you enter this program you join a family
we stand together that's what makes us
strong
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
I'll help me save the world Pacific Rim
uprising gives an answer back to those
monsters that we've grown up watching if
they were to attack us what would we
have we have the Eggers the fight
sequences of different than any other
movie I've ever done you're plugged in
and you're along for the ride Amara
built scrapper she's committed her whole
life to this Jaeger there's things about
the kaiju that we've never seen before
it's just epic
I can announce that this is the most
action I've ever done
it's like can a ticket to the best books
in my shepherd
[Music]
you
you